what do you mean your people what do you
mean your people you're russians
did you hear what she said about
russians did you hear what she says
russians i love russians you know what i
didn't love the russian recruiting video
that came out that [ __ ] was terrifying
did you watch it i told you about it of
course you didn't watch it i didn't
watch it oh shocker
um
the usa put out a recruiting video yes
and then like a day or two later russia
put one out
and the recruiting fruit video in the
states was a
animation of uh a female soldier yeah
with two moms and she was gonna go
change the world
right russia came up with one
it's like it's the the character from
like rocky
essentially and there are guys in the
mud and just in the rain just [ __ ]
doing push-ups just pushing it out
they're just like they see their boot
they're just like crushing things and
i'm like and it's all like in the deep
russian voice i'm like oh my god yeah
which one is better would you say which
bothers you
more
what do you mean by bother specify
so deception is a funny thing because
when you're young and you're choosing to
go to the military or not it's not like
you know
like none of us know what the best
trajectory for life is right for many
people going to the military is a really
makes them incredible human beings some
of the best people in this world i know
are soldiers so it's i'm not i don't
mean like it's somehow bad to go to the
military i think it's a great choice but
there is something
the honest truth is i just don't like
marketing people well
and so this is essentially a marketing
effort yeah it is a marketing effort so
which one do you like as a marketing
effort better russia
yeah there you go i do because canada
doesn't you know what our recruiting
videos are it's like um
uh i love it they're the best sorry a
yeah oh [ __ ] here we go it's starting it
started awesome
so canada does these ones where it's
like um it'll have
a bunch of like soldiers doing movements
and then they'll like snip it together
really quick it'll be like a navy one
and then a guy jumping of a plane and
then it'll be like an artillery and then
like an armored and it'll be like
join the canadian forces today and like
that's like their
their videos so it's like very
marketable very palatable to canadians
who don't really want war and who don't
really acknowledge their military in the
first place and do everything they can
to make sure that vets don't get any
support when they come home
so they i can see why that one is uh
acceptable what russia did
was meant to be more of an intimidation
tactic in my opinion
i like that style better though i think
we need harder i need i think we need
people to be harder i think it's
acceptable and okay to say that our
soldiers need to have a harder mindset a
stronger mindset a better mentality and
mental health support going into the
service and a harder body
because i know
when you go to the u.s i've also
encountered plenty of soldiers that are
600 pounds
what are you gonna do
you